hey i'm luna isaacs welcome to my power
of young hollywood cover shoot little
nausea is among the stars fronting
variety's power of young hollywood issue
in a candid new interview lil nas opened
up about homophobic comments directed at
him from others in the industry saying
the honest truth is i don't want to
speak on a lot of the homophobia within
rap because i feel like this is a very
dangerous playing field it's more for my
own safety rather than anything else lil
nas also reflected on coming out back in
2019 during pride month i definitely
knew that i would lose a lot of the fans
that i was gaining but i also knew that
others would be supportive and having
that release helped me so much
creatively i probably wouldn't even be
here right now talking about the things
i'm talking about and being that voice
for so many people it's so much more of
a journey when there's more to it than
just making catchy songs you know the
interview also hit on when lil nausex
first knew that he was gay he said i had
feelings for my sister's cousin we have
different dads i was like oh my god he's
really cute and thought that about a lot
of other boys my age
[Music]
and one of the highlights in little
nozzex's life is meeting and dancing
with beyonce at her halloween bash back
in 2019. so what words of wisdom did
beyonce share with the star lil galzax
explained she just said she's super
proud of me and to keep going it was a
next level experience and we all know
lilna's ex was and continues to be a
stan of nicki minaj and he explained why
saying i felt like minaj was unique to
the rap industry somebody who was super
talented but didn't get all the credit
because of her being a woman she's super
outspoken she's a boss and she goes
after what she wants and sorry everyone
it seems like little nausea is off the
market he spoke about finding the one
saying i've had some good boyfriends and
some bad ones a lot of them were
emotionally unavailable or had a lot of
insecurity and whatnot adding i found
someone special now i think this is the
one i can't explain it it's just a
feeling
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos